[Música]
y ahora hablamos de economía ya está
conmigo en el estudio Jorge Hurtado
Jorge muy buenas noches Hablamos ahora
de los representantes de la Popular
aplicación tiktok que muchos de Ustedes
deben usar que advirtieron en el
congreso de Estados Unidos que vetarlo
perjudicaría la economía bueno el
consejero delegado de esta aplicación
dijo que hay miles de negocios en ese
país que se verían perjudicados ya que
usan la aplicación para impulsar sus
emprendimientos pero la comparecencia de
Show en el congreso de Estados Unidos no
sirvió para calmar esta campaña
bipartidista dirigida en su contra
durante su intervención show se enfrentó
a preguntas muy directas de parte de los
miembros de ambos partidos que buscan
vetar esta aplicación por considerarla
un riesgo a la seguridad nacional
Estados Unidos Canadá y la comisión
europea ya vetaron la descarga y el uso
de tiktok de los dispositivos
gubernamentales en Estados Unidos se
presentaron incluso proyectos de ley que
buscan prohibir su uso a nivel nacional
porque consideran que los datos de los
usuarios podría caminar en manos del
partido comunista chino tiktok Busca
calmar las preocupaciones sobre esta
influencia china con una inversión de
1500 millones de dólares en medidas de
seguridad de datos con sede en Estados
Unidos pero esta propuesta ha sido
rechazada por el funcionario del
gobierno estadounidense que exigen que
bidance que es la empresa dueña de esta
aplicación venda sus acciones o sea
prohibida en Estados Unidos escuchemos
parte de la acalorado debate que hubo
hoy todos los países del Mundo están
diciendo que tiktok no es una empresa
privada es parte del partido comunista
chino Qué dice usted sí o no forma parte
del partido comunista chino como todo el
mundo piensa o sigue usted viviendo en
un mundo Místico no estoy de acuerdo en
muchas conclusiones usted vive en un
mundo Místico a las afueras del Congreso
un grupo de creadores de contenido e
influencers protestaron en contra del
veto de esta aplicación Según dicen si
desaparece sus ingresos se verán
perjudicados escuchemos
una prohibición de tiktok no solo pondrá
en riesgo mi negocio el 95% de mi
sustento desaparecería de la noche a la
mañana junto con toda esta comunidad de
creadores y clientes que he construido
sobre la plataforma
tiktok ha hecho mucho más que solo darme
exposición de hecho me ha permitido
aumentar mis ingresos en un 700% y este
dinero adicional me ha permitido
mantenerme construir un estudio y pagar
al personal y si me quitan esta
plataforma no estoy seguro de poder
seguirlo haciendo Jorge hablemos ahora
de México donde la inflación parece que
está comenzando a ceder algo positivo
Bueno hablamos de la inflación general
que sorprendió al mercado mexicano con
su cuarto descenso quincenal consecutivo
mientras el sector privado esperaba un
dato quincenal del 7,24% en la inflación
el Instituto Nacional de estadísticas y
geografía informó que la tasa cayó el
7,12% en la primera quincena de marzo
ahora los expertos esperan que la
inflación general Cierre en marzo en
ciento baje el 6% en mayo y termine 2023
ligeramente por encima del 5%, pese a
ello la inflación Aún se mantiene por
encima del objetivo del Banco Central
que era del 3% y es superior a la de
países como Estados Unidos y Brasil por
esto se espera que el emisor suba en 25
puntos base la tasa de interés de
referencia una medida que por supuesto
Busca controlar este acelerado aumento
de los precios esperemos que cumplan
estas predicciones Jorge seguimos en
América Latina porque china levantó una
prohibición a las importaciones de la
carne brasileña importantísimo para la
economía de ese país bueno estas
importaciones fueron suspendidas desde
el 23 de febrero luego de un caso
aislado y atípico de vaca loca la
reanudación del comercio se da tras la
visita a Beijing del ministro de
agricultura brasileño Carlos favarro y
también previo a la llegada del
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula Silva
programada para este domingo Lula no va
solo a China lo hacen compañía de 240
representantes empresariales
de ellos específicamente el sector
agrícola esto es una muy buena noticia
para Brasil país que es el principal
exportador de carne vacuna a nivel
global y China por supuesto su mayor
consumidor solamente en 2022 el país
asiático compró a Brasil carne bovina
por ocho mil millones de dólares el 8,9%
del total de sus importaciones y pasamos
al Reino Unido que subió nuevamente los
tipos de interés Bueno este aumento es
de un cuarto de punto porcentual ubica
ahora en el 4,25% y se trata de la
undécima subida consecutiva que busca
controlar también la inflación que está
en el 10,4% anual el inesperado subidón
de la inflación que pasó del 10,1 al
10,4 en febrero hizo prácticamente
Inevitable esta decisión mayoritaria del
comité monetario en ese país el aumento
en el precio del dinero es la cifra más
alta registrada en Reino Unido desde la
crisis financiera e inmobiliaria del año
2008 el banco inglés se suma a la
política de seguridad de tipos de
interés de bancos del banco europeo y
también de la reserva Federal de Estados
Unidos que aprobaron aumentos
recientemente Jorge muchas gracias por
este reporte del mundo de la economía a
continuación en directo a América ya
viene el debate